Pokemon scarlet and violet is just
around the corner and with it are some
sweeping changes coming to the Pokemon
formula here are 11 of the biggest
changes we've found so far number one a
seamless open world Pokemon scarlet and
violet is shaping up to be the first
truly open world Pokemon game Arceus
which was released earlier this year has
a handful of open areas but they were
separated by loading screens and this
adventure players will be able to
explore a seamless world at their own
Leisure as a longtime Pokemon fan this
is exciting news Arceus kind of
scratched this itch back in January but
scarlet and Violet's open world seems to
be a lot more ambitious although some of
those textures look a little whack
number two non-linear progression there
are three major stories you can chase in
scarlet and violet Victory Road Starfall
Street and path of Legends Victory Road
is the good old gym challenge that has
you defeat eight gym leaders however
unlike every other Mainline game in the
series it seems as though you can tackle
gyms in any order you see fit though if
this is the case we still aren't sure
how the gym challenge will be balanced
will the gym leaders team change
depending on how many badges you have or
will some gyms be way too hard from the
outset if a gym Leader's Pokemon scales
and level does that also mean they could
have different teams depending on when
you challenge them one thing we do know
is that due to terrestrializing a new
feature I'll talk about in a little bit
a gym leader could feasibly use any
Pokemon regardless of its initial type
as long as it has the correct Terror
type in a couple trailers we saw
brassius the grass type gym leader use
the rock type Pokemon sudowuru now we'll
touch on the other major story lines
later in the video so stay
number three Champion rank once you've
defeated all eight gym leaders you can
take a champion assessment we aren't
entirely sure what this assessment
entails but I imagine it will be similar
to the Elite Four in previous games if
you complete it you'll achieve Champion
Rank and you'll be able to challenge
other Champion ranked trainers
throughout the region hopefully this
means that we'll get some challenging
post-game battles outside of the tried
and true battle tower number 4 to
rasterize Pokemon that brings us to
terasterizing this allows you to change
a Pokemon's type mid battle using
something called a Terra orb you can
only use this orb once per battle and it
must be recharged after use every
Pokemon in the paudia region has a
terror type and a Pokemon's Terror type
can be any of the 18 different types
meaning every Pokemon can rasterize and
potentially change its type mid battle
the best way to get Pokemon with rare
Terra types is either by finding
sparkling Pokemon in the wild like this
Jigglypuff or by doing Terror raid
battles which are multiplayer battles
that allow you to catch powerful Pokemon
on with rare Terra types generally it
seems like common Pokemon you find in
the wild will have a terror type that
matches one of their original types
while rare Pokemon have a Terra type
that's different I'm really curious to
see how this affects the meta especially
at higher level play hopefully we'll see
some really creative teams at the
professional level number five Titan
Pokemon along with the Victory Road
questline you'll be helping a new
character named Arvin gather a rare
ingredient called Urban mystica in the
path of Legends quest the catch is not
that these herbs will get you high but
that they are guarded by Titan Pokemon
these Titan Pokemon are much bigger than
normal and offer a greater challenge
based on the trailer and the position of
the Pokemon's HP bar it looks like these
will be treated as boss battles
scattered throughout the world it also
looks like you'll need to find and
challenge some of these Pokemon multiple
times as cloth in the trailer scurries
away when his health gets low number six
Starfall Street the third quest line
revolves around team star a group of
class cutting delinquents as the
official Pokemon website puts it who
have formed a series of bases around the
paldeo region as most young Pokemon
trainers do when they are confronted by
a dangerous group of shady individuals
you'll need to challenge them to Pokemon
battles however these battles could play
out a little differently in the most
recent trailer we saw a trainer enter a
Starfall base and kick off a large-scale
Auto Battle it looks like in these
situations you'll be able to send out
two Pokemon at a time to battle for you
though battles do return to normal once
you confront the base's boss number 7
auto battles you heard me right Auto
Battles Pokemon scarlet and violet
introduces the let's go feature this
allows you to send out your lead Pokemon
to gather items and take on wild Pokemon
on its own to earn XP it's important to
note that this is different from sword
and Shield's polka jobs that allowed you
to send out Pokemon on their own through
a PC let's go happens in real time
meaning you can follow your partner
Pokemon if you'd like or you can take
care of other Pokemon related business
personally I'll probably avoid doing
this because if one of my Pokemon
automatically knocks out a shiny I will
be livid number eight crafting crafting
was already an Arceus but scarlet and
violet will allow you to craft TMS with
items you collect from battling and
catching Pokemon at every Pokemon Center
you'll find a green PC that will allow
you to either craft TMS or exchange
materials for League points it appears
every TM will require resources from a
specific Pokemon and something called
League points both can be earned and
collected through catching and battling
Pokemon number nine picnics Pokemon
scarlet and violet will let you host a
picnic with your beloved Pokemon in many
ways these picnics feel like expanded
versions of camps from sword and shield
you can bathe them play with them and
feed them during a picnic you can make a
sandwich with some of the ingredients
you've gathered during your adventure
look there's even ham sandwiches will
give your Pokemon party passive XP Buffs
as well as make certain types easier to
catch Additionally you can sometimes
find eggs in your picnic basket it's
unclear if this happens by random or if
egg breeding now takes place during a
picnic seems a little unhygienic to me
but hey if that means I don't have to
keep a running back to Pokemon breeders
that's A-Okay by me number 10
multiplayer multiplayer has been a
staple of the Pokemon series since red
and blue scarlet and violet is taking it
to the next level with Co-op play
players will be able to explore the
world with up to three friends now we
aren't sure how standard turn-based
battles will work while your friends are
mosing about the world but it should be
interesting nonetheless along with
trading and battling you can also take
on terror raid battles with fellow
trainers like the raids in Pokemon sword
and shield these let you team up with
some friends in order to defeat and
catch a rare Pokemon unlike sword and
shield though these battles seem to play
out a little differently than regular
turn-based battles number 11 changes to
legendaries the legendary Pokemon always
play a huge role in these games however
it looks like you might be teaming up
with the mascot legendaries Corydon and
Mariah ride on at the very beginning of
your adventure it's hard to say when
you'll first encounter these Pokemon but
considering how important they are for
traversal I think it's safe to say that
you'll meet both of them within the
first couple hours both legendaries take
the form of motorcycles although Corydon
despite having Wheels uses his legs to
move I was torn on which version to get
until I saw this I will be getting
Violet thank you very much and there it
is 11 of the biggest changes coming to
Pokemon scarlet and violet let us know
what you're most excited about in the
comments below personally I can't wait
to see how this non-linear story
progression shakes out scarlet and
violet hits shelves on November 18th
this year so stay tuned to Gamespot
because we have plenty more Pokemon
coverage coming your way very soon
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]